hello welcome to this video playing
picasso that says vrd zoriah I think
your pants are pretty strong Grandmaster
now in residing for a couple of years in
the u.s. think is from Georgia already
already originally I'm sorry so this is
interesting if I Vigo cancels and I
completely have forgotten the details so
let's see what we get
okay takes it yeah so Bishop see to AC
able to capture I don't know let's just
do this night ext3 is not something that
bothers me that much 25 I can i have
three okay so
have you how do you handle of the snow
queen e 7 or we are probably out can do
Queenie 7 it's not a big deal and I tiff
five unfortunately counter-attacking the
sea for porn so I have to be a little
bit alergia stuff like Bishop h3
sometimes does work for nye def two
forks of three forks I'm sorry me not
right here but this is a motif that is
sometimes possible yeah yeah just I just
want to trade the dark squared Bishop
trade the night and then try to impress
your eyes 36 pawn I like this kind of
pollution seems very one-sided
okay sf4 move or is that weakening
mostly it is weakening mostly so the
night cannot treat that night somehow I
don't see how I can do that but maybe
here i was thinking i was mentioning
bishop area and now i did not pay any
attention okay if you moves the queen of
f4 f5 that's going to be dangerous but
ok anyway d 6 is hanging I actually
could have taken that maybe it's got
night see for ideas Oh came here for
isn't that just working always the
trickery he's a very tricky tactical
player but no less no trickery he just
has to give material now ok so I cannot
take these 693 though seems good
okay 95 it's not yet working this one
maybe 45 'if I've and Bishop g5 of this
kind of thing yeah threatening a five
now and getting one getting on the dark
squares
okay hey I should win this now this
looks this looks really completely
winning yeah that's the only thing that
I'm kind of gap at these holds things
together for the movement keep things
together but it shouldn't shouldn't work
in the long run and five is a threat f5
Queen takes Knight h6 or pawn takes
Knight f6 lettuce and then 92f for it's
going to be decisive I guess and he has
no ID ective museum
black resign now the blacks opening
result here was simply too bad it was
not a playable position I mean around
here I think I like my position quite a
lot Black has very little that he can do
he's got this week d6 porn and no active
plane I mean he tried to do something
yeah what what the higher rated player
does like play complicated whatever but
it doesn't just worsen his position yeah
he could have taken on age 3 i'm gonna
have f4 but it's a it's a mess that
that's what's his chance ya to mess up
the position and like cheeks takes
Knight takes bishop jakes that might be
better for white but with the computer
likes white slight edge but it's very
messy yeah after that and FYI i'm
basically winning now the thing is if he
goes back which looks like the normal if
I have f5 and I just win it was the
problem yeah and this is I think quite
strong ideas I five and and yeah if he
takes that I have this coming and he's
got no activity yeah this is this is
good i mean we place a non-move I've got
night f6 or f5 as I mentioned it's also
pretty strong as this is winning the
Queen jack or here now 56 and Jack I saw
this line and thought that there should
be enough this is what's the engineering
plus 10
10 is good okay I was a good win against
when Master thanks for watching